those of you playing the division will
likely have noticed a whole lot of
things have changed since the last
update yeah okay some of you just lost
your characters and I keep running into
this the awesome problem but aside from
that there are also a bunch of new ways
to get Phoenix credits unfortunately
you're now getting less of them for
doing the same tasks and some items
appear to be a lot more expensive than
they used to be but if chasing the best
gear is your jam you'll need to pick up
a [ __ ] ton of this fancy currency it is
worth knowing that some methods of
getting Phoenix credits are a hell of a
lot more efficient than others as I'm
sure you've noticed each day lets you
dig into a variety of daily missions as
well as new daily and weekly assignments
and an incursion mode the incursion
offers up 15 Phoenix credits for beating
it on hard and 44 challenging but it
will take you way longer than other
credit gathering methods unless you cut
it up to the nines with amazing gear in
which case you probably do not need my
suggestions that said if you want those
new green gear set items the incursion
is the way to go for the rest of you
sporting a more modest gear score I'd
initially recommend you check out the
new assignments and rewards for each
mission once they refresh this way you
can figure out what rewards are worth
chasing and do a bit of mission
combining for example if a combat
assignment offered up 10 Phoenix credits
for taking out a named enemy you should
take out one who appears in a daily hard
mission which probably takes you around
10 to 15 minutes and rewards you with an
extra 10 Phoenix credits for your
trouble as for the weekly assignments
I'd recommend ignoring them for the most
part as they aren't great to value for
time investment since it offers the same
amount of Phoenix credits that you'll
get for running one challenging mission
through which you can do at any time
yeah I imagine they'll change that if
you're into the idea of weeklies though
here's how you can go about it you're
more than likely going to end up
fulfilling most of this so-called
strategic assignment incidentally for
example taking out 40 veteran or as they
call them purple dudes is probably going
to happen anyway as is completing 10
missions in a week assuming you usually
knock out the dailies when you have a
little extra time on your hands I'd
recommend cleaning up there
just a bit to get your 30 Phoenix
credits and just keep any other
objectives in the back of your mind like
deconstructing materials for some
unknown reason or whatever else it may
be then there are the new combat
assignments which may ask you to kill up
a certain enemy type thankfully there's
only four types of dudes who want to
shoot you in the face in New York City
so chances are good you'll run into the
ones you have a quest to kill in one of
your dailies so this one should happen
without you trying too hard if not you
know the map pretty well now so you can
hunt down cleaners rioters or whatever
to your heart's content pretty easily
since you quite literally know where
they live it might not be the most
exciting thing ever but if all you want
to do is grind for Phoenix credits best
way to go about it is to keep running
Lincoln Tunnel on challenging since it's
pretty easy as far as division missions
go and you don't make any less or more
famous credits and depending on the
organic mission difficulty for your
heart and challenging daily missions the
fastest way to get the rhythm is to be
mindful of your team dynamic if you like
me can't find three dedicated friends to
help you out on a regular basis the
matchmaking system has your back this
may seem a tad scummy but it's worth
checking out the other members of your
group before you roll out since their
gear score and talents will make a huge
difference to how quickly you can get
through a mission it'll also hurry
things along if you have a strong team
who is proficient at holding a line
super helpful at getting one another
back on their feet with quick revives
and with a varied amount of talents use
the marking system by aiming at an enemy
and pressing up on the d-pad so team
members know who to shoot or guns
pointed at one level 32 elite work a lot
better than one and the faster you get
these missions done the faster you get
those Phoenix credits in your pockets
there's a reason the game strongly
recommends you go into a challenge
mission with a full team and chances are
you know the mission map so well now
that you can be an [ __ ] and spawn
camp the AI yep spawn camping is finally
a thing working in your favor I'll just
loan range of the missions and play solo
while enjoying the far far fewer enemies
if that works best for you finally it's
not my personal favorite way to farm
Phoenix credits but if you're a fan of
bounty hunting named enemies will always
shop 1 2 3 Phoenix credits
as well as high-end items this method
works best with a strong grip in the
dark zone since the landmarks will
almost always be home to named enemies
and you can take out a lot quite quickly
that said if you don't have the best
gear or a reliable squad you may find
this method isn't worth the trouble
because of all the dying you're doing so
if you've been groaning at the inflation
of prices in post-apocalyptic Manhattan
like I have hopefully these mostly
common sense suggestions will help you
out a little happy Phoenix credit
hunting